welcome to this video playing Joseph
from Norway can the name Zoe okay let's
do this again last game I won with this
opening okay
I can also castle like has various moves
orders move orders this moves what is a
bit a bit some uncommon it is a specific
case where black gets in Knight to e7
very often black plays Queen e75 then
retreats to be aid while working on my
book I found out that very often it's
quite nice to get the knight to e7 okay
um I can play can't even go Bishop a5
and 90 for him maybe
[Music]
a five maybe a five takes 94 now could
be interesting try to make my good
development count for something
94 or not hmm yeah maybe
[Music]
quickly played
okay I'll take him and I will place his
six at the end of that check I guess or
maybe B 5 B 5 is also move 5 if form
yeah maybe B 5 interesting
[Music]
[Music]
yeah whatever you can say but he's
playing all this very quickly
[Music]
even if like a three which you really
didn't want one to play but he has no
problems to do it as it seems okay um
how do you tell you i activate my nine
only seven I cannot yet sacrifice
something maybe I need to do this
get the knight to f6 and it also
introduces Queenie Troy to the position
[Music]
okay the chick on Queen g5 first no I
can also go Queen to be aid trying to
get the pawn back I probably get it back
so maybe do that it's not so much the
pawn but if I get the bb5 pawn I can
also play against a beefed-up on
[Music]
yeah this I completely overlooked
I have bishop yet down okay so you still
cannot cancel
my tough position
yeah I take too much time it's really
nothing nothing special going on here I
just take too much time
[Music]
[Music]
okay let's see a king to e7 yeah this
double pawn is is pretty much worthless
that he has I think I can no is doing
away with the Queen I don't know what
he's doing if he's not keeping c7
attacked I'm playing for the win here
because of the better better better
structure check
[Music]
[Music]
yeah there's really nothing going on
okay you can get the night somewhere
here I don't know on a 6e would at xe7
but I don't see this happening
maybe I should really get the knight to
f6 to to keep his pieces tied to you for
maybe yeah maybe do that King is 7 97 96
could be good
[Music]
yeah that's of course interesting once
you once to get it to a 6-time morning
okay and on here this I overlooked
I can take this 700 no I really I really
screwed that up it was very difficult to
lose this and he does not see it okay
[Music]
yeah the position is okay now who I
guess
[Music]
[Music]
mm-hmm yeah I really don't have much
time
[Music]
jay-j yeah
[Music]
check
[Music]
[Music]
check-check black for a fix on time yeah
the only way to lose it
yeah it's it's a bit it's a bit of old
over time of course there is no way to
to win this position but I really wonder
what I did wrong at the start of the
endgame I really shouldn't be in any
sort of trouble shy around TM hmm that's
some other way to to set up the pieces
[Music]
yeah I guess it's okay you cannot really
do something active
I can shuffle around him yeah 95 was was
interesting I can the computer says I
can take it but it's it's difficult
difficult to do that
I was just believing him there thinking
that my structure is some is healthy
anyway but I what I overlooked is
overall so 97 he can we can always take
him which he I don't know over look you
didn't see whatever track and she white
really has a pawn I can put the King on
b6 though mice can open up the King's
heart this should lose in the long run
but he didn't do that yeah
probably this this idea I mean the the
position here is obviously very good to
black but I made the wrong choice iam
somewhere and wonder where I mean at
least black should be okay the the setup
here is wrong than ever
the red shows Bishop h5 could be
interesting then Knight g6 maybe I need
to activate the night I think black
should be okay because when I have the
rook in play and tears King is only one
he's got this this double porn app but
this is the extra pawn I can get that
get it to b6 to the night I shouldn't be
be bad shouldn't be worse iam this was a
very positional way to do it maybe this
is better this is better
hmm this is this is the point really if
he now tries to keep it
I go Queen g5 and this is very nice
yeah something like that this is the
point so this is how to how to get get a
good position yeah no MP must give it
back yeah and okay when I'm not even a
pawn down for the position I remember it
satisfied now this is a good structure
yeah this is what I should do but okay
it's it's difficult difficult to spot
this looked very normal really and it's
not like it's anything grateful white
[Music]
yeah he gets he gets out of it he does
not have any problem him in the other
position I have some chances to to do
something forward and yeah it's just I
can just shuffle around okay thanks for
watching